Chris waters here folks with Lee and
Jesse from alien trap games what's up
guys so good it's going great GDC week
and you guys are showing off a new game
we are puffy on is out and it's on to
the next thing and the next thing is
cryptarch
let's let's see this thing in action and
we'll sort of form our idea of what what
is all going on here cuz you guys jump
from project to project and they're very
different so this is a very different
project than yeah capsized or apatheia
every every game we make is a reaction
to the previous game we make so this is
our reaction to apathy on being a
massively you know long story scripted
narrative thing so this is not that it's
not like that crimped arc is not that
yeah we wanted something a little more
you know look a little quicker and make
and and more rebuild replayability and
you know just something that people can
dive into right away and have fun with
so we're looking at a procedurally
generated map of an alien spaceship yeah
so this is a very very early build we've
been working on this build for like
maybe a month we had some prototype
prototypes before that mm-hm but
essentially you're playing as a space
pirate to space freelancer and you're
you're tasked with kind of taking over
these alien spaceships and knocking out
their central core but in order to do
that you can't just go right to the core
you can shoot over to the core all these
ships have different security systems on
them so you it's all about kind of
looking at a map pre-planning what order
you're going to tackle things in in
order to get to the core so it's
actually you know there's shield systems
the particular systems or door systems
that lock all the doors down there's
factories and make enemies there's
systems like control turrets all that
kind of stuff mm-hmm so if you kind of
target them and knock them out you can
make your life a lot easier means you'll
and make them be a lot less like a lot
like bone do cyber bots goddess look
here what well I really like doom I
think I'm excited demons are like the
coolest thing in the world yeah oh yeah
we got so we got cyber skeletons nice
it's kind of a homage to that yeah this
is a this is kind of a system map so
he's
he's looking to destroy the core a big
big brain mm-hmm but all these red
squares are different systems that he
can hurt or contused to take out and
you'll be going into each mission with
with only limit amount of ammo a little
bit about a health and you won't be able
to take out everything like it no you
can't do a full clean sweep of about me
the clean sweep there's no way you're
just too much going on there's almost
too much stuff
okay actually one of the things I think
this is fairly close to is we really
liked Parker three and four credit for
the outpost that is not what I would say
looking at this kid it is close to but
but with the up house you know you're
you're it's a nice kind of
self-contained little little area yeah
you're going up to it you're kind of
surveying it okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go
here and let's go know if it's alarm I'm
gonna hit a barricade or whatever we're
gonna try it out and then it all goes to
hell and then you have to kind of
reformulate a new plan on the fly where
it all goes perfectly that dragon I was
created by one of the juggernaut systems
oh really these guys come yeah every
five minutes yeah so he's essentially
like a little mini boss in the level
effect and if he doesn't care about
doors comes right through and even if
you kill them they'll come back if the
system is still up so one way to do that
would be to take the system out another
way would just to be real quick about
exactly you only have to deal with one
of them in your in your exploration and
so the way you're dealing with it like
it looks you know we're seeing a pretty
basic machine gun type weapon in action
but there's also a grenade launcher from
time to time yeah and then one that I
was using what I got when I have played
a demo was it's like a dash attack yeah
we have like some a laconic eight some
energy so I type things so the the way
it'll work is you know Oh II this is
kind of a moment-to-moment level play
don't be kind of an overarching
economy-based metagame so when you when
you beat a chip when you when you
destroy poor you'll get money or hey you
get paid for that cuz that's a circle
job yeah and then you'll be able to use
that for new weapons new items and all
that kind of stuff
but if you die during ship you lose the
investment that you put into it so
basically you start a ship you look at
how you think you gonna tackle it you
buy certain weapons about
you probably were gonna tackle you buy
ammo you buy this caliber shield buy
this chainsaw etc and that outlay you're
gonna you're not gonna hold on any of
that stuff if you get blowing exactly
it's it's it's very much at risk reward
system defending yourself against the
level so if you're gonna you know say
you're trans Accola really really
difficult yep it has like thermal
systems I really need to check out that
repair system - I've got to do at the
start because if I don't think that at
first it repairs the ones that I've
already destroyed yeah it's like hell
but the shield system is already a third
of the way yeah no it's like you've made
no progress
if you don't kind of be at that so so
yeah you're kind of betting yourself
against against the system so if you're
you're trying to talk about really hard
level do you bring do you bring you know
the most expensive most awesome you know
for rocket launchers and the new person
like that mm-hmm
and then if you beat the level your
profit isn't gonna be super huge because
you spent all your money on guns going
in on the systems to beat it exactly but
if you dive and you lose all that money
or are you like okay I think I'm skilled
I think I'm fast enough to be able to
tackle this really the fellowship with
my own handicaps put onto it I'm gonna
bring like just little people he started
peashooter and like nothing else if you
somehow managed to pull that off but
it's in your teeth and you'll get a
massive pay it's a big payday yeah so
it's kind of a self balancing thing as
to what you think you can accomplish and
so there are a lot of these systems
you're talking about are sort of you
know like it's meant to be that kind of
contained gameplay experience it's not
the long narrative adventure of a poppy
on its the it's a sort of one-off
challenges of like I'm going to take on
sort of this ship and then see how that
goes exactly right taking on another
ship a 10-hour game yeah yeah if it
seems no more narrative yeah like we'll
have narrative elements but there'll be
more of you know kind of a framework
kind of hold everything together sure
like what what kind of pirate are you
wired exactly I'm wondering the aliens
all about can even be able to customize
your look or is that like yeah thanks
good I think we're calling him gun head
it's good do you have two guns on his
head and then one on each arm
essentially yeah so the working title
yeah I think I'm gonna what the name's
never going through that but yeah you'll
be able to come into any mission with
four weapons and they're on all the
shoulder buttons and triggers and then
four items and then you know whatever
combination better have you decide to
bring along okay I see the items it's
they're like d-pad indicator in the
bottom line yeah so you could bring like
you know three health kits and like the
landmine or you know cloaking kits or
you can give up your item slots for
chance to make more money or you know
all these kind of different variations
of things or bring more ammo or or you
know have like teleport beacons or you
know all these kind of just crazy
gadgets and stuff like that are you guys
still kind of brainstorming well yeah to
put in there yes i mean i they you know
that i think the problem or the tricky
part about one of these games is like
you look at a map like that and i would
imagine like part of the impulses i
gonna make the best maze i got a what if
we put it here so it's like fiendishly
difficult like like as a designer you
know the temptation i imagine is there
to design every every sort of space in a
different way to sort of presented it
for challenge or different cadence or
different piece but it's sort of where
do you draw the line between wanting to
do that but also wanting to have this
kind of procedural generation elements
is it's not fun to like it's better to I
finally gave more fun when it's
constantly different for me that's like
my main motivation really is to do
procedural generation you just don't you
don't want to have the first level
design and then you have to test that
one over and over I'm very sick is about
the odds first level there's so much
okay and and the nice thing I think
about this is the way the systems
interact with each other so for instance
you know one kids of system is shielding
another and the repair system is fixing
that one and you know another one is
alarmed and all these kind of things I
think that's what really makes the
procedures that are agent interesting
because you know even if the you know
the actual walls and stuff are are
the difficulty comes from having to look
at what support systems are what what
systems are interacting with those
systems and how you're gonna kind of
dismantle them all mm-hmm and then what
and you know for you guys in terms of
designing the systems what what sort of
consequences can arise from like if you
leave these two but neglect to this one
or sweep through around this way but
leave these other things you know that
that sort of goes towards D and it kind
of harks back to your farcry comparison
that kind of emergent stuff yeah yeah
you know that is what makes procedural
generation so fascinating is how stuff
can just go wrong yeah it's very unfair
like if it's just luck like bad luck
that makes you lose the level I'm fine
with that yeah I think well and we
really wanted to be like you know if
when the player dies they've lost the
bet that they made
basically okay but you're talking about
also that's like a tough line to
straddle out imagine physically at the
one time you want players to you know be
able to make an informed decision when
they're gambling but with their loadouts
and deciding like I'm gonna take this
and try to go for this payout yeah but
at the same time you you want to design
levels that are tough enough that not
every loadouts gonna work and and I
think that is just that that comes down
to how you review a many people have
actually beat this demos ever done that
I had that I was talking about you in
five that's all right yeah we beat the
game began games over
yeah so guys cryptarch is still still
early days for it this is an early build
you've got a lot a lot of ambition
coming into this game and a lot of sort
of it seems like energy to make
something different yeah I knew you're
just really for yourselves even we do
you have any kind of release kind of
format or window at all or we just kind
of yeah we're still in the exciting part
of you know the similarly designed is a
console game like yeah control yep
you're playing on a controller this is
being done on a lab so we don't know
anything about release its weight of
course of course well thank you guys
anyways for coming and showing off early
I mean for an early game it's looking
pretty slick and pretty intriguing but
looking forward to seeing how it shakes
out thanks a lot
you